[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
zu Ostern habe ich mir überlegt dass wir
meinen Cheesecake Trend wieder
aufgreifen und Cheesecakes Sticks machen
in Osterode im osterlook so das ganze
soll später aussehen wie so kleine süße
Häschen aber ihr könnt sie auch gerne
mit Blümchen dekorieren oder auch gerne
ganz anders jedenfalls habe ich mir
heute gedacht machen wir vielleicht
sogar einen Himbeer Cheesecake ihr könnt
auch Erdbeere machen ihr könnt auch
Schokolade machen Eierlikör Pistazien
cheese geht ganz wie ihr möchtet
jedenfalls fange ich jetzt schon mal an
mit einem Mürbeteig der ganz klassische
Teig und der geht so
dafür verwende ich 240 Gramm kalte
Butter 120 Gramm Zucker eine Prise Salz
und Vanilleextrakt 360 Gramm Mehl und
ein Ei für den Mürbeteig nehmt ihr jetzt
die Butter die habe ich bereits in
Würfel geschnitten verrührt Sie oder für
knetet sie mit dem Zucker und Salz
Vanilleextrakt kommt auch mit dazu und
dann gebt ihr nach und nach das Mehl
dazu und das Ei das ganze nicht so lange
kneten damit die Zutaten schön kalt
bleiben anschließend wird er einfach zu
einer Kugel geformt abgedeckt und darf
dann eine Stunde in den Kühlschrank und
diese Zeit nutze ich dann um die
käsekuchenmasse vorzubereiten für die
käsekuchenmasse nehme ich 150 g weiche
Butter 200 g Zucker etwas Vanilleextrakt
5 Eier Zitronensaft 500 g Magerquark 50
Gramm Stärke und jeweils 240g Joghurt
und Sahne für die käsekuchenmasse
verrühre ich zuerst die weiche Butter
mit Zucker und Vanilleextrakt für zwei
drei Minuten gebe dann nach und nach
jeweils ein Ei dazu und rühre es gut ein
anschließend kommt noch der Zitronensaft
dazu mit Quark
Speisestärke mit rein und alles schön
Klümpchen frei verrühren und
anschließend kommen dann auf der Joghurt
und die Sahne dazu
jetzt ist der Teig gut abgekühlt und die
käsekuchenmasse ist fertig ich mache das
jetzt so ihr könnt natürlich eine große
Springform nehmen ich habe aber den Teig
so zubereitet dass es zwei Springform
sind mit 20 cm Durchmesser damit die
käsekuchensticks nicht so groß sind
sondern eher kleine Portionen also der
Teig und die Masse reicht genau für zwei
Springform mit 20 cm ich habe jetzt hier
auch den Tortenring bereits auf diesen
spring vom Boden gegeben Ofen vorgeheizt
und dann sollte das ganz gut passen
so habe ich zumindest mit meiner App
ausgerechnet da kann man ja immer die
Größe eingeben von den Backformen und
einfach was hoch oder runterrechnen wenn
ich zum Beispiel eine Torte habe mit 20
cm will aber dann Blechkuchen draus
machen da könnt ihr das in der App
eintragen müssen nichts mehr rechnen das
macht dann nämlich die App für euch das
ist ganz praktisch
perfekt
dann einfach kurz geschmeidig kneten und
halbieren dann passt es genau für die
zwei Formen
[Musik]
geschmeidig aber noch trotzdem schön
kalt
einmal kurz halbieren und jetzt braucht
ihr hier die Backform auch nicht
einfetten sondern ihr nehmt jetzt hier
euren Teig
macht da so kleine Rollen so lange
Stränge das wird nämlich ein Käsekuchen
mit Rand
die strenge legt ihr hier dran und
drückt sie dann so ein bisschen mit den
Fingern fest und der restliche Teig
kommt auf dem Boden und den Rolle ich
dann so rein
[Musik]
hier könnt ihr jetzt in der Mitte den
Teig einfach mit den Fingern so ein
bisschen verteilen und damit dann schön
gleichmäßig wird nehmt ihr einfach so
eine Backform Rolle z.B oder drückst mit
dem Glas einfach gekauft
und genauso mit diesem Rand hier mache
ich das jetzt auch für die zweite Form
ich habe jetzt hier beide Backformen
ausgekleidet habe jetzt hier die
käsekuchenmasse und es ist noch gar
nicht schlimm wenn die bei
Raumtemperatur stehen bleibt die soll
nämlich auch schön warm werden dann
reicht der Käsekuchen auch weniger das
ist tatsächlich echt so ein lifehack
jetzt kann ich das hier einfach
einfüllen schön gleichmäßig
[Musik]
dann am besten kurz klopfen
dann ist auch die Luft schön raus und
dann geht es ganz in den Backofen
der Kuchen kommt jetzt in Backofen und
ich mache es beim Käsekuchen immer gerne
so dass ich den so ungefähr nach 20 30
Minuten einmal auf der Oberfläche
einschneidet dass er nicht reisst und
dann wird er im Ofen gebacken was er
aber auch machen könnt ist ihr könnt den
Kuchen auch so ein bisschen mit
Wasserdampf backen dann reißt er auch
nicht also wenn ihr z.B auch eine Bosch
Backofen besitzt mit Dampf Funktion ich
habe noch eine Luftblase gesehen wird
auch eine Bosch Backofen besitzt mit
Dampffunktion dann könnt ihr da den
Dampf einschalten und dann reißt der
Käsekuchen noch nicht also kommt da
jetzt in den Backofen mit gebacken darf
darin auskühlen und dann geht's später
weiter mit der Deko
[Musik]
so sieht der Käsekuchen jetzt aus der
ist jetzt noch lauwarm ich werde ihn
jetzt aber schon mal abdecken und dann
kommt er über Nacht in den Kühlschrank
ich mache dann nämlich morgen weiter und
morgen kommt dann die cheesecake-sticks
rein also die die keksticks und dann
werden daraus Cheesecakes Sticks genau
vorbereiten gut abkühlen lassen ich habe
tatsächlich eine Kleinigkeit vergessen
ich wollte ja eigentlich ein
himbeerkäsekuchen machen ich habe Dich
immer vergessen
ich dachte nämlich ich nehme
gefriergetrocknete Himbeeren und
pulverisiere sie und rühre sie in die
Masse ein ich habe es vergessen egal wir
machen da trotzdem schöne draußen der
Käsekuchen war über Nacht im Kühlschrank
zu spät jetzt löse ich ihn hier raus
aber ihr sollte den mindestens 3 Stunden
auf jeden Fall kühlen damit er kalt
genug ist zum durchschneiden
ein Teiler der hat 16 und 12 Stücke ich
nehme jetzt mal die 16 Schneide aber
dann nur 8 zu damit sie nicht ganz so
dünn sind
aber so können das ganz schön einteilen
einfach ein schönes scharfes Messer
nehmen und glatte Schnitte machen und
deswegen ist auch wichtig dass der
Käsekuchen richtig kalt ist denn
ansonsten ist er zu cremig und dann
lässt er sich eben nicht gut schneiden
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier etwas weiße
Schokolade geschmolzen die hilft dabei
dass der Holzstiel gleich im Kuchen
schön stecken bleibt ich habe hier
einfach reiste
ich rede einfach weiter okay und damit
die alle auf der gleichen Höhe stecken
nämlich
nehme ich einen Abstand
so rum hin
dann tauche ich den Stiel in die weiß
Schokolade
[Musik]
ich habe den Kuchen hier auf einem
tortenretter das heißt ihr könnt die
Stiele auch hier schön abmessen dann
sind sie nämlich alle gleichmäßig
[Musik]
dann lege ich sie mit etwas Abstand auf
ein Backblech was in den Gefrierschrank
passt dann kann man sie nämlich super
einfrieren
und das dauert dann so etwa 3 Stunden
eigentlich es reicht auch eigentlich
eine Stunde aber bei 3 Stunden ist da
einfach sicher es passt aber wenn ihr
den Kuchen vorher schon so wie ich jetzt
über Nacht im Kühlschrank hattet dann
reicht der locker eine Stunde
fertig machen und dann geht's gleich mit
der Deko los ich freue mich schon auf
die süßen kleinen Häschen
[Musik]
während die Käsekuchen Sticks jetzt noch
im Kühlfach holen kann ich schon mal
überlegen wie ich die Deko machen werde
dazu nehme ich jetzt noch mal so ein 20
cm so ein Springform Boden denn ich
möchte ja Häschen machen und da ist es
echt ganz gut wenn ihr euch vorher
überlegt wie sie aussehen sollen
dann zeichne ich mir hier diese Achtel
ein
und dann geht man da nicht so planlos
ran
ich habe jetzt überlegt das ganze so ein
bisschen im
asiatischen kawais-stil zu machen ist so
kleine süße Häschen
[Musik]
für die Deko nehme ich jetzt etwas
Fondant ihr könnt auch Modelliermasse
nehmen und von dann einfach mit
Blütenpaste oder mit cmc-pulver also
Cellulose Pulver verkneten dann härtet
das ganze nämlich auch gut aus bei den
Ohren werde ich das auch so machen also
dann nehme ich dann weißen Fondant und
macht ein bisschen CMC rein für die
Augen nehme ich jetzt hier einfach etwas
schwarz da brauche ich jetzt keinen cm
und das wird jetzt schön dünn ausgerollt
und dann mit so kleinen Spritztüllen so
wie hier zum Beispiel einfach
ausgestochen
die geschlossenen Augen die steche ich
auch aus und ihr könnt auch immer die
Spritztülle so ein bisschen den Bäcker
Stärke tauchen dann nehmt ihr nämlich
einen kleinen Kreis
und steche dann noch mal drüber dann
habt ihr diese schöne diese schöne Welle
[Musik]
für die Ohren nehme ich jetzt weiß und
damit die Ohren gleich groß sind könnt
ihr erstmal eine Kugel formen die dann
halbieren dann habt ihr nämlich
exakt die gleiche Größe dann forme ich
das noch mal zu einer Kugel und zu einer
Art Tropfen
und hier kommt jetzt so ein bisschen
Modellierwerkzeug zum Einsatz ihr könnt
so ein goldtool nehmen und immer mal im
bäckerstärke tauchen und dann hier
einfach in der Mitte entlangfahren dann
bekommt ihr nämlich so richtig süße
dreidimensionale Ohren
ihr könnt ja auch ein bisschen länger
machen oder ein bisschen dicker so wie
ihr das halt mögt
könnt ihr euch hier so ein kleines
Stückchen rosa nehmen und einfach die
Innenfläche an den Ohren ankleben dann
nehme ich einfach essbaren Kleber dafür
ihr könnt aber auch Wasser nehmen
und für die kleine süße Stupsnase nehme
ich jetzt auch rosa Form eine Kugel und
dann könnt ihr das so zwischen den
Fingern so ein bisschen dreieckig Formen
und werden süßes Herzchen draus machen
will kann oben noch sowieso einen
kleinen Schlitz reinmachen
ihr könnt aber auch wenn ihr das nicht
machen wollt einfach ein Herzchen
streudekor benutzen dann können wir
nämlich einfach ein Herz drauflegen
[Musik]
lasst eure Kinder einfach 16 kleine Mini
stupsen Mädchen machen das ist
Beschäftigungstherapie
jetzt noch die kleinen Zähne dran dafür
nehme ich jetzt etwas weißen Fondant
ob es hier dünn ausgerollt
und schneide jetzt einfach kleine
Rechtecke zu
[Musik]
entschlossen ich mache acht Häschen und
acht Frühlingsmotive
die Deko haben wir jetzt schon mal
vorbereitet
und ich habe jetzt hier etwas weiße
Kuvertüre geschmolzen nämlich zwei
Drittel in der Mikrowelle einfach ich
mache das dann einfach bei Mikrowelle
höchste Stufe bei mir sind es knapp 800
Watt und rührt und immer mal wieder und
es war jetzt so nach zweieinhalb Minuten
geschmolzen jetzt kommt noch mal ein
Drittel Kuvertüre dazu das darfst du
machen
alles rein
genau darfst du wegschmeißen
und das was ich jetzt hier mache ist die
impfmethode weißt du was die Methode ist
und zwar habe ich jetzt zwei Drittel
Kuvertüre geschmolzen in der Mikrowelle
geht aber auch über dem warmen Wasserbad
und dann gibt ja ein Drittel Kuvertüre
noch mit dazu und impft sozusagen die
Schokolade also die Kuvertüre damit sie
später in den richtigen festen Zustand
kommt das heißt dass sie später schön am
Fest wird und glänzt keinen grauen
Schleier bekommt und deswegen macht man
das so und kann es sein dass manche
kleine Stückchen nicht ganz schmelzen
aber dann geht man noch mal übers warme
Wasserbad oder kurz in die Mikrowelle
oder nimmt einen Heißluftfön und dann
habt ihr die perfekte
weiterverarbeitungs Temperatur
ja
Max den schon mal holen der ist da
hinten guck mal auf ganz rechts in der
Schublade
aber hätte auch das ostervideo und
Osterhasenkostüm nehmen können aber wir
nehmen mal lieber Pummeluff
[Musik]
jetzt die Kuvertüre perfekt ich habe
auch so eine
schokoladenprobe gemacht ich habe
einfach die Teigkarte zur mit der Spitze
eingetaucht kurz hier liegen lassen auf
der Arbeitsfläche und die ist dann schön
fest geworden innerhalb von einer Minute
ungefähr jetzt muss natürlich alles
etwas schnell gehen ich fülle das jetzt
in ein höheres Gefäß um
das habe ich vorher ein bisschen
angewärmt bei mir ist nämlich der
Nachteil in der Küche tatsächlich ich
liebe meine Arbeitsplatte die
Steinplatte die ist nämlich mega robust
da passiert gar nichts aber natürlich
habe ich auch immer eine kalte Platte
und gerade wenn ihr mit Schokolade
arbeitet er mein ich meine könnt ihr
euch zum Vorteil nehmen und dann eben
die Sachen schön auskühlen lassen aber
ist natürlich auch ein kleiner Nachteil
wenn man Dinge warm halten will deswegen
lege ich dann gerne so eine
universalmatte drunter so eine
Antirutschmatte damit die Kuvertüre
nicht sofort auskühlt
und jetzt nehmt ihr euch den Cheesecake
Stick ich mache jetzt acht Ruby und acht
weiße taucht sie hier ein Streife kurz
ab und dann lege ich sie hier auf die
Backfolie
ich nehme einfach wieder meinen
spritzbeutelständer
ich wusste es
ich sitze immer gern einmal ab und dann
oben
damit sie nicht so diesen Fuß am Rand
bekommen das so die überflüssige
Kuvertüre einfach wieder weg ist ich
hole den
deshalb auch praktisch weil da quasi die
Form schon perfekt ist
[Musik]
vier weiße habe ich schon fertig die
vier nächsten werde ich direkt mit einem
frühlingsmotiv dekorieren denn ich weiß
nicht ob ihr davon euch Häschen
nachmachen wird also gibt es noch ein
schönes frühjahrsmotiv ihr könnt da
diese süßen Schokoeier nehmen die
kleinen bunten Gummibärchen Eier oder
diese diese soften Eier die es eben zur
Osterzeit gibt oder ihr macht einfach
etwas was euch eben am besten gefällt
ich habe jetzt hier ein paar gehobelte
Mandeln ich habe ein paar Pistazien
gehabt und habe so kleine süße Blümchen
und das kommt jetzt hier gleich drauf
und da mache ich das direkt drauf
während die Schokolade noch weich ist
und fest und bevor sie fest ist damit
eben die Deko schön drauf trocknet
[Musik]
ich zeige euch jetzt noch eine Methode
wie ihr auch kleine Öhrchen machen könnt
aus der Kuvertüre ich meine bei
Cheesecake Sticks ist natürlich so ihr
habt dann extrem viel Kuvertüre übrig
weil ihr natürlich ein bisschen was
braucht zum eindecken das ist einfach
geht aber ihr könnt die übrige Kuvertüre
einfach in kleine Eiswürfelbehälter
geben fest werden lassen und beim
nächsten Mal wieder benutzen oder falls
ihr eine Freundin habt die gerne weiße
Kuvertüre ist Filter ihr sie einfach ins
Glas dann könnt ihr euch Backpapier
nehmen und darunter zum Beispiel eine
Schablone legen wo ihr die euch in
aufzeichnet
und schneidet ihr vorne so eine Spitze
weg und könnt mit der Kuvertüre eben
auch so kleine Öhrchen aufzeichnen erst
mit weißer Kuvertüre und dann mit der
rosanen rubik-kuvertüre drüber
dann geht's weiter mit Ruby
ich habe mich jetzt die Ruby Kuvertüre
das ist diese hier und Ruby Schokolade
ist ja die vierte Schokoladensorte neben
Weiß Vollmilch und Zartbitter und es ist
eine ganz natürliche Kuvertüre das heißt
die rosane Farbe die ist wirklich in der
Kakaobohne drin und es ist was ganz ganz
besonderes und die schmeckt so ein
bisschen fruchtig so ein bisschen
säuerlich und richtig gut also ich finde
die schmeckt sogar so ein bisschen nach
Himbeere das heißt da sind jetzt keine
zusätzlichen Farbstoffe mit drin sondern
die Kuvertüre ist eben einfach so was
ganz besonderes so sollte man jetzt hier
noch ein paar Meter Ruby und da mache
ich es auch so vier Stück lasse ich
Aushärten für die kleinen Häschen und
vier Stück bekommen direkt drauf
schön abtropfen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt nehmt ihr ein bisschen restliche
Kuvertüre in den mini-spritzbeutel und
tript das so über die Spitze drüber am
besten in beiden Farben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und die kommen jetzt den Kühlschrank
denn im Kühlschrank kann der Cheesecake
jetzt auftauen und dann ist er richtig
schön cremig und dann können wir ihn
probieren aber erstmal morgen
[Musik]
die sind so süß
stellt jetzt auch noch mal kurz in
Kühlschrank und dann probieren wir sie
gleich okay kommt ihr zwei zuckerhäschen
ihr dürft jetzt hier probieren
Ella was sind Oster cheesecake-sticks
und Ella hat augenzucker Näschen und wie
gefallen sie euch voll cool richtig
schön
schöne Geschenkidee zu Ostern welche
gefallen mir mehr gefallen
dann probieren wir jetzt mal ja kommen
wir probieren dann darfst du den ersten
bis machen
deine Nase ist abgefallen
okay
ich habe tatsächlich vergessen ich
wollte eigentlich ein himbeerkäsekuchen
machen okay ich wollte so gefräge
trocknete Himbeeren reinrühren ich habe
es vergessen könnt ihr machen habt ihr
noch mal so ein
Säure drin ja aber ich finde es auch so
gut ich bin Fan von Ruby Schokolade
[Musik]
zum Mond und zurück
drei Jahre und was sagt Mama immer ich
liebe dich
[Musik]
dreimal um den Jupiter
dann wieder zurück auf den Mond und auf
die Erde zurück
ja so sehr liebe also cooles Rezept und
frohe Ostern würde ich sagen
ich hoffe ihr probiert die mal aus ihr
könnt auch zum Beispiel ein Eierlikör
Cheesecake machen
mit Pistazie also ganz egal wie Ihr
möchtet auf jeden Fall finde ich schön
wenn ihr das ganze schön frühlingsmäßig
mit Blümchen oder Häschen dekoriert und
wenn ihr sie nachmacht dann postet doch
gerne ein Foto davon auf Instagram und
verlinkt uns dann teile ich nämlich eure
Beiträge auch hast du instagram
[Gelächter]
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss machs gut
Ella stimmt doch gar nicht nein kommen
wir jetzt noch verpacken und verschenken
ich lass die bei mir und ihr zwei könnt
jetzt schon mal spielen gehen okay
tschüss
[Musik]